are you a gambler are you a gambling man
no do you like gambling on horses or you
know like sports or any of that
you don't play cars you don't play dice
you don't you don't play crabs you don't
play any of that
no really you're missing out man no i
was the reason why i was going to ask
you but would you say
uh uh are you
are you the kind of guy that when you
were 25 years old at a bar you saw a hot
girl did you overthink it in your mind
and say you know i don't know if i want
to go talk to her because what if she
says no or were you kind of like i'm
just going to go talk to her you took
the risk and you spoke to her neither
neither what did you just sat there and
she came to you that's right we're not
part of that league
so you had life easy this so even before
you were tinder so they were swiping you
right
was what you were tinder do you know
what tinder is no believe me they made
it after you tinder is like a dating
site in america dating app yeah yeah
it's a dating app that guys used to
swipe right to get
but but going going back i don't think
you needed it though but going back to
you
your personality is not at all risky are
you like the guy that hey let's go jump
off that cliff you're like i don't want
to jump off that cliff of course it's
risky
which risks am i prepared to take
no well no okay so then
no because to me
marriage is risky having kids is risky
going into business is risky moving to
paris is risky
different all
life is risky right taking a position
with faith is risky deciding to do
almost anything today is risky right so
look i understand the position of
assuming formlessness which means
never like hey you guys i i understand
your position i disagree with this but i
understand this position but i disagree
with this and i kind of stay here that's
a safe
not risky position but you also don't
create enemies
so so you kind of stay in a place where
enemies are not being created but
oh you'd be surprised how are you making
enemies so who are your enemies i don't
i don't see people this like even when
your debate with hitch on sitchins was
very respectful and he wasn't it wasn't
as typical he was more vicious towards
his brother than he was to you you guys
had a very nice debate
we had an extremely pleasant debate
don't forget he was terribly ill at the
time i don't think he had the energy or
the vigor really to
do a full court press i don't think so
it was a one hour it wasn't a three hour
i i it was a one-hour debate isn't that
kind of like
not the point of the debate to have a
nice pleasant debate
it depends whether you're dealing with a
man at the brink of death or not a lot
depends on that
i mean if he had been indisposed with a
headache that would have been one thing
but he was dying of cancer and that
changed all the parameters at least it
did it for me
i was in absolutely no mood to attack
him
got it pat you're asking about risk for
a reason yeah i want to go to that i
wanted to elaborate on that i wanted to
unpack that uh
the question of he you come across as
a guy that would be the risky guy you've
taken bigger risks in your life at this
phase of your life at 80
do you sit there and say well like
inside when you're by yourself nobody's
around you're sitting at a coffee shop
in paris you're having your nice
croissant and the same waitress is
coming to you and you're speaking to her
and you're reading the paper or whatever
book you would be reading and you're
saying
okay david we kind of got a risk and
take one of them what do we want to do
is it going to be jew is it going to be
christian is it going to be aldias are
we going catholic are we going to go
muslim let's take it let's pick one of
them i got a 20 chance
you know i'm gonna go baha'i because
baha'i welcomes all the religions you
don't think about it like a little like
pascal's wager isn't it i mean that's
the question you really asked me when i
accept pascal's weight what is pascal's
17th century he had a wonderful
theological argument about commitment
commitment to god belief in god
he said look what do you lose
what do you lose
if you commit yourself to god and you
live a
god-fearing life
and god exists well that's a terrific
benefit you've come out ahead of the
game
and if he doesn't
exist what have you lost he lost nothing
in game theory that's called the
dominant strategy no matter what it's
better to believe in god
if you don't believe in god and he
exists you're in for an awfully hard
time
and if you don't believe in god and he
doesn't exist well
nothing changes so why is that a bad
approach i don't think it's a bad
approach at all
i think it's an excellent approach and
everyone i've talked to
when i translate that argument into
practical terms agree yes i accept
pascal's wager he was right and he was
right that doesn't mean that the
argument
well you're saying he's right but you're
not willing to accept pascal's weight
yeah but that's the limitation of an
argument you know there are many
arguments i i can consider whether
premises are true the conclusion follows
logically but it doesn't mean anything
to me if you enjoyed this short clip
click over here to watch another short
clip and if you want to watch the entire
episode the entire podcast click here
[Music]
you